what's up everyone welcome to the video
today we're going to take a look at how
to replace the battery in this Jeep
remote key fob
this cheap key fob is going to use
replacement battery
CR2032 and I'll put a link in the
description box of this video to where
you can purchase these batteries if
you're in need
the other thing I'm going to be using to
do this is a flathead screwdriver
the first thing I'm going to do is
remove the emergency key that's in the
bottom of the key fob
that's done by pressing this release on
the back of the key fob
hold that release down
and then the emergency key will slide
out like that
we can just set that to the side
now if we grab our screwdriver and we
hold the key fob with the buttons facing
down and then we take a look at the
bottom of it
this is the slot that that emergency key
slid out of just below that we see this
Notch right here
what I'm going to do is put my
screwdriver in that Notch push it in as
far as it will go and then I'm going to
twist the screwdriver like I'm opening a
lock with a key
and as I do that it splits the two
halves of the shell apart like that
go ahead and pull them the rest of the
way apart
and in the back half of the shell we see
our battery right here
then I'm going to grab my screwdriver
again and in this plastic holder there's
a little cutout you can see right there
that'll allow you to get under the edge
of the battery
and get it out of that holder
then I'm going to grab the new battery
and we want to make sure that we're
installing that with the plus side down
like that
and you can see in this holder there's
this little metal piece right here
that's the edge we're going to tuck in
first like that so tuck that edge in
first
and then snap it the rest of the way
down
and then we can put the two halves of
the shell back together
make sure it's all the way back together
Slide the emergency key back in
and that's it
if you could take a second to like And
subscribe it helps us out and I'd
appreciate it
thank you